welcome to simply learns machine
learning engineer salary skills and
resume my name is Richard Kirchner with
the simply learned team that's WWMT
learn comm get certified get ahead
what's in it for you we'll start with an
introduction to machine learning
responsibilities of a machine learning
engineer machine learning engineer
salary trends skills of machine learning
engineer and we'll go over a brief
machine learning engineer resume or an
example so what is machine learning
machine learning is a study of
algorithms and data models that computer
systems utilize to perform specific
tasks without using instructions relying
on previous patterns if we have to build
a robot with human-like intelligence it
should be able to learn for itself with
previous experiences this is where the
role of a machine learning engineer
comes in you can see this picture where
we have humorously the human has no face
and the robot does or maybe the one on
the right is a robot and the one on the
left is a human dressed up this is where
the role of machine learning engineer
comes in who is a machine learning
engineer a machine learning engineer is
someone who performs the following tasks
develops and implements production-ready
algorithms and methods this is a very
difficult challenge because we talk
about production-ready that's a key word
in here this is something that's going
to be pushed out to end-users to be able
to use whether it's a bank doing their
finances or your new cell phone where
it's doing some kind of image adjustment
and adding in virtual images or stamps
onto the picture code evolves machine
learning solutions with data scientists
and engineers so you'd be working as a
team the data scientists are going to be
developing this and then you're gonna be
implementing it provides technical
guidance to product teams on the choice
of machine learning approaches
appropriate for the task machine
learning engineers will design implement
and ship new algorithms provides
architectural guidance on changing
prototypes to high-performance
production models and provides feedback
on tools and new features required to
send it back to the development teams so
let's take a little deeper into the
responsibilities of a machine learning
engineer they study and transform data
science prototypes these
machine learning systems implement
machine learning algorithms develop
machine learning applications select
appropriate data sets that is so huge in
the machine learning engineer is how do
you get these data sets in there and how
do you use appropriate once I mean
that's gonna go back and forth to your
data scientist as a machine learning
engineer you want to be able to
recommend stuff for them and then they
got to go back and prototype it and then
it comes back to you to put it together
and start training these neural networks
perform statistical analysis and fine
tuning and train and retrain systems
when necessary and that's also another
big one because there's a lot of upkeep
on these if you've ever seen the
evolution of any of the current AI is
out there from Google Voice to all the
different picture programs and
everything there's a continual
retraining of these systems going on and
they continually improve so they're not
just rebuilding the whole thing from the
bottom up sometimes they're just
retraining them to get a better response
what's most exciting about this and what
most people are in here for is gonna be
salary trends of a machine learning
engineer so where does that fit in and
the money show me the money and we look
at the salary tree ins the salary trends
of a machine learning engineer we look
at the average base pay and this is for
the u.s. it's one hundred twenty one
thousand seven hundred and seven dollars
and you can see right there there's our
average around 122 K low in is 83 K so
if you're just getting into the field
and you're looking for a pretty ship
kind of thing that's where you start
looking at 83 K and then once you have
that high-end expertise now you're
looking at 162 K so it's got a really
nice salary to it in the u.s. the
average salary of a machine-learning
engineer in the United States is 121 707
per year and if we look at that we skip
over to India the average salary of a
machine learning engineer in India is
750 thousand per year 750 K in Indian
Standards and it ranges from the lower
383 to 1584 K and that's important to
note that one of the interesting things
is in India if you're coming in as an
apprentice you have a lot more room to
breathe there and there's more jobs
available where in the US it's a little
harder to get it at the beginning but
once you're in there once you get your
foot in the door your salary just shoots
up with you
into the upper-end machine learning
engineered jobs and we're going to this
is just a pull off of in deeds best jobs
in the u.s. in comparing average base
salary to percentage growth in job
postings 2015 to 2018 and this data was
pulled back in March this year 2019 and
you can see here as we just kind of go
across there you can look at all the
different salaries going up and
certainly the machine learning engineer
has just shot up because it's one of the
primary growing fields and it's not
stopping I mean this this is we're in
such an infant stage of machine learning
and training and how do we get into
these deep learning models so the graph
shows the average base salary versus a
growth in job postings from 2015 to 2018
the red line indicates the growth in job
postings a machine learning engineer it
is observed that machine learning
engineer has a three hundred and forty
four percent growth of job postings from
2015 to 2019 again that's not gonna stop
that's just gonna keep rising because
that is where a lot of the actual work
is right now stuff is being pushed out
they've got it working now they need a
machine learning engineer to go in there
and do all that retraining and fine
tuning and that's a huge job and it's
it's a growing industry it's just gonna
continue to take off so we look at top
companies hiring for machine learning
engineers we got Amazon Apple Deloitte I
hope I said that right
uber facebook spotify Google Microsoft
Cisco Bosh all of these should look for
me these are all the big tech companies
and we're starting to see a filter into
the small companies in fact I was just
reading an article that had one of the
neural networks that's used in deep
learning tensorflow
has a tensorflow light that runs on an
adrenal board if you know anything about
Adreno that is the $35 that's US dollar
cheap computer in a box that you can
build something and strap it on there
and actually run a really simple neural
network obviously you're not going to be
doing some high-end graphics but you can
certainly use it for doing a lot of
little things so across the board
companies are hiring machine learning
engineers now we look at the skills of a
machine learning engineer as we start
looking for word machine learning
engineer should have the following
skills one programming pick a program
master it if you don't already
you should have at least two / solid
programs under your belt in machine
learning the top program right now is
Python with the close following of Java
there's also scale is very big when
we're talking about a lot of this in any
of these programs you should be able to
be really solid in one programming skill
and be able to adapt to another one so
having a secondary one at least should
be important because you never know when
you walk into a job what people want the
program might start in Python and in
dance gala and then they do realize that
they need to push it out onto the server
and it's a Java code that they want so
and it's not as hard as you think to
switch between the codes but it does
require you have a little knowledge in
each of those codes and be a master of
one applied mathematics you must have
basic understanding of math and this is
becoming less and less important but
it's still you need to have some
fundamental knowledge of your
mathematics data modeling and evaluation
that is so central to what starts
separating it from a programmer or from
a data scientist is your data modeling
and how to evaluate these different
models so very important skill machine
learning algorithms and libraries that's
just the vocabulary it's a vocabulary of
data modeling and evolution machine
learning algorithms and libraries that's
just the language of data modeling and
evaluation you have to understand all
the different algorithms and libraries
and what's going on there so that you
can model different data and evaluate it
under the different models so let's take
a look at programming programming
ability to adapt implement and make
changes to the programs when required
programming languages like C C++ Java
Python our studio I didn't mention art
because it's so that's also one of the
big data science programs that are out
there and again right now Python just
topped the chart our studio for data
science Java is way up there see play
any of these are really hardcore so
master if you're if you have a master in
any of these great you should know
something and be able to just glance
into Python and probably glance a little
bit into R is important too because
those are the current data science
programs being used so you can actually
look at this and be able to know what to
pull and what to push we talked about
applied mathematics understanding of
matrixes that's probably the thing that
trips a lot of people up in mathematics
even people who are pretty solid in
mathematics start looking at matrixes
and
they just start looking at columns and
rows and eyes go dilated so
understanding your matrix isn't being
able to manipulate them derivatives and
integrals is necessary so you have an
understanding of your basic derivative
and what that means statistical concepts
like mean standard deviation is required
you really need to know those
terminologies and what the standard
deviation means what a square means any
of those concepts median versus mode
versus any of those things those are so
important when you're doing applied
mathematics and you're looking at data
science and in this case the engineering
side of it and understanding a
probability algorithms like naive Bayes
mixture models is required data modeling
and evaluation data modeling is a
process of finding the hidden structure
of a given data set and finding patterns
such as correlations and clusters a key
part of the process is evaluating how
good a given model is and choosing an
appropriate accuracy error measure and
an evaluation strategy now one of the
things I find interesting in the field
is that people start looking at the data
modelling and you can write a script
that goes through all the different
models and then it can take some of
those models and change all the
different underlying dimensions for that
model that takes up a lot of processing
so you might do that and very basic or
small part of your data set but as you
fine-tune it you start learning that
understanding the it's almost like a
kind of a the art form of data modeling
right now is in this area is which how
do you find those correlations which
cluster control do you want do you are
you training it or are you just finding
things that match some of these things
go with some other things and you're
just clustering it based on their
features understanding all that is is
really the art form digging into the
data science and data engineering side
and as a machine learning engineer this
is important to be able to understand as
we look at machine learning algorithms
and libraries you need a firm
understanding of algorithm concepts like
linear regression support vector machine
k-means etc and understanding how these
algorithms work and so this is kind of a
rehash of some of the other things we
saw earlier and this is a vocabulary you
need to know this vocabulary you need to
know when you're looking at linear
regression model versus just
regression model what's the difference
you can't just throw one into the other
well actually you can but if you throw
one into the other you don't get as good
of a result and then you waste a lot of
time messing with the wrong thing and
understanding your packages libraries
and API is like scikit-learn that's part
of the mainly Python although it's
spilling over and being adapted in other
areas see no tensorflow pandas and numpy
you know all huge package is currently
being run for the machine learning
algorithms to give you an idea we'll go
over to the the simply learned website
and you can see data scientist here and
when you come in here you can see
there's a whole series a lot of times we
start with our programming this isn't by
accident our programming is was the
standard of data science for so long so
you'll see data science SAS Python deep
training SAS has come in that's a it's
one of the major players but it's not
one of the big programming languages
your Python your machine learning again
here's a more specific tableau which is
very highly used in the industry Hadoop
and spark important to have a basics of
Big Data again this is all stuff as its
gonna come up if you're as a data
engineer or data scientist and there's a
lot of other ones here including all the
way through the master programming so a
lot of tools here that you can look up
and set up as far as getting your skills
up to par for being a machine learning
engineer and of course the bottom line
is where is the money you know it's if
we're gonna train depending on where
you're at in your career a resume of
machine learning engineer is important
to understand and they've changed so
much I remember my first we won't talk
about how long ago my first paper and
machine learning was my first resume I
put out for a work and job and
applications resumes have changed so
much and when we talk about something
like a machine learning engineer they're
going in leaps and bounds and let's just
go ahead and pop open a quick template
here and just show you some ideas of
what we're looking at so and I've opened
this up into a simple PDF reader Adobe
Acrobat Reader one of the first things
is that and this always catches me off
guard as we're starting to see where we
want to see the person and you can
actually put your photo on the resume it
stands
out there gonna remember you you know
wear a tie a suit and tie look nice be a
professional on this one but that's a
big thing now it catches people eyes and
we I've seen that forever say in the
real estate industry they hand you their
business card and it has her photo on it
even back in the 90s they didn't care
long as they had that visual so we want
a name a face an email id contact number
but we really want that name in bold and
we really want to see who you are this
is such a shift from the way it used to
be it used to be that you did not want
your personal stuff on your resume now
you do and of course the summary is very
important you can see right here and
again there's different options on this
so this format isn't necessarily the
only format you need to use but this is
a really good place to start as you can
see here we're actually using almost a
third of the page to put your name put
your summary and this next part is
another one another huge one your
LinkedIn profile if you have it they
start looking at that and you have all
you post all of your stuff on there
nowadays they ask you hey what's your
history what's your claim in history and
they can go down with your
certifications suddenly this LinkedIn
has all this massive amount information
that they can go pull and find out more
about you without having to go through
the resume so the resume is almost
secondary at some point and another
really important shift we see is where's
your github link or someplace maybe you
have a personal website someplace you
can show your skills and coding your
skills and what you do so they no longer
want to just have a resume that says
yeah I'm good they want to actually see
what you're capable of this is a huge
shift in resumes today and with that I'm
gonna give a quick warning though as I
come in there and I look up people when
they say hey do I want this person to
work for me I'm gonna do a search on
them they're gonna do a search on your
name when you're looking for a job so
remember your Facebook and all your
personalized stuff if it is public
make sure it's professional you know you
don't want to have someone go in there
and decide they don't like you because
your favorite rock band is imagine
dragons or and also keep in mind that
sometimes those Facebook posts show up
on somebody else's feed so even though
you think you're private remember any of
that stuff could end up public and your
employer might be looking at that in
some jobs you might want to highlight
that
if your specialty is marketing and
you're using Facebook and marketing put
that in here so again it gives them
another link of what you do and what
you're doing on your resume we come down
to experience this can go in different
areas a lot of times if you have been in
the programming industry for years you
know I have over two decades as a
programmer this is almost a secondary
page sometimes more I just have all the
companies listed that I've worked for
with the blurb about what I did for them
again a lot of people just go to
LinkedIn and they already see that
information so they're gonna skip right
over it so you might even bump it down
to the bottom and then your education
and skills in a lot of cases you might
take your skills and bump them to the
top highlight yourself and then have
your education and certifications again
it depends on your history and what your
strengths is if you have very specific
skills your highlighting you might want
to bump this to the top so the company
is aware of it
but again we have a very basic blurb
experience education skills
certifications this goes with education
sometimes a range that that's gonna
highlight you and show you off the best
so if you're really big on
certifications you might put those next
and just have two columns of all the
certifications you've gone through and
where they came from and then maybe your
education maybe you have oh an
associate's degree so you might have 20
different certifications and a two-year
associate's degree so the education
might go underneath your certifications
and so on again organize this to
highlight you and your strengths and
also to target the company you're
looking for in a resume I just love the
switch over here on the top and there's
even another suggestion you could even
do a personalized video again now they
have a this is a sales and marketing
thing and we're starting to talk about
where we have a physical page they're
looking at hopefully you've talked to
them on the telephone so they have their
voice in the air and a video would be a
third input so the more the different
inputs they have forth being the website
maybe a personal website would beef if
you have a Facebook that's
semi-professional on there and
addressing and addressing what you're
going after put that stuff in here the
more input somebody gets the more
rounded they see you and the more they
might want to employ you as a human
being instead of just another page on
their stack of people to go through
I hope we were able to find some gyms in
here to help you along with your career
whether you're trying to decide what
you're gonna do next what certification
you want to get next and what learning
courses you want to take or if you're at
that point we're gearing up to market
yourself what's the final steps you need
to get there thank you for joining us
today for more information visit
www.gfi.com/webmonitor these channels
and answer the questions on there or
come to our website and join one of our
communities where we have more
information and we have moderators to do
go in there and answer questions on our
website along with a live talk you can
go into and talk to somebody and get in
the right direction hi there if you like
this video subscribe to the simple learn
youtube channel and click here to watch
similar videos to nerd up and get
certified
click here